when fred was a kid back on earth maybe
five or six years old he'd seen a weed
growing in the darkness of his uncle's
cellar the plant had been pale and thin
but twice as tall as the ones out in the
side yard deformed by reaching for the
sunlight the man behind the bar
looked just like that too tall too pale
too hungry for something he'd never had
and never would belters were like that
the music in the bar mixed punjabi
rhythms with a high voiced woman rapping
in the polyglot mess of languages that
made up belter creel the battered
pachinko machine in the back
rang and skittered hashi smoke sweet in
the air fred leaned back on a bar stool
meant for someone 10 centimeters taller
than he was
and smiled gently is there a [ __ ]
problem he asked
the bartender could have been chinese or
korean or a mix of the two
which meant his family had probably come
up in one of the first waves
five generations of grubbing for air
packing extended families into surveying
ships with seven bunks looking back at
the sun that was hardly more than the
brightest star
it was hard to think of any of them as
humans anymore
hey guys pete here in light of recent
events i wanted to do a video about fred
johnson
i've been getting a lot of questions
about the belters in general
on my season 5 videos and i think the
short story about fred
the butcher of anderson station provides
some great insight into life in the belt
and the struggles that belters face
before we get into the origin story of
the earther who became the leader of the
moderate faction of the outer planets
alliance
i think we should touch on the history
of the belt and how belters came to be
in the first place
we'll start there so the name the belt
comes from the asteroid belt in our
solar system
between the orbits of mars and jupiter
as its name implies it's a bunch of
asteroids
big and small all different shapes and
sizes
that are grouped together in a belt
orbiting the sun these rocks are made up
of significant amounts of valuable
materials
things like ice which you can use for
water rare minerals
and precious metals and they're just out
there waiting to be claimed and then
mined it's a gold rush waiting to happen
it's just currently they're out of our
reach
roughly 130 years before the events in
the expanse pickup a martian engineer
named solomon epstein
invents what will become to be known as
the epstein drive
without getting too far into the details
the epstein drive is
a really efficient fusion drive that
makes it possible for humanity to
explore and colonize
our solar system at the time of its
invention mars was still a colony
of earth they'd been wanting to break
away so they shared this technology
for their independence and that opened
the door for both planets to go out and
extract those resources i was just
talking about
as that extraction was taking place we
had people who relocated to these
colonies indefinitely
those are the original belters for
additional context
on earth at that time there were a
number of factors that would contribute
to people wanting to go out to the belt
to try to strike it rich
due to the increased population there's
literally not enough jobs to go around
so about half of the population lives on
a sustenance
level basic income and are literally not
allowed to work
there's also limitations on who can have
children you have to pay a big tax to do
it legally
so as you can imagine there's a
ready-made population
for an opportunity like this i mentioned
it was a gold rush waiting to happen
and i think of it as being similar to
the california gold rush in the 19th
century you had this mass migration of
people going there trying to get rich
but if you know the history of it the
reality is not many of the miners
actually did
the real fortunes of the gold rush were
the people who were selling these guys
materials selling them
food and overpriced tools and supplies
belters become a new exploitable class
of laborers
who after a few generations of living in
low g start to develop differently than
humans that grew up in earth's gravity
and that further otherizes them they're
taller
thinner and their bones become brittle
in a way that makes living in gravity
very difficult
these differences also make it easier
for people from earth and mars to
dehumanize them
they call them skinnies they see them
basically as second-class citizens
and as you might imagine this all sets
the table for
conflict i suppose for practical reasons
the show doesn't really depict them as
they are in the book we see a little bit
of that whenever avasarala tortures as
suspected
opa terrorists but generally speaking we
don't see the differences in characters
like miller or naomi
instead the show plays up the cultural
differences a little bit more
so instead of being really tall and
skinny people with tattoos and speaking
belter creole the tattoos and the belt
to creole is what gives them away
anderson station is a ore refinery
that's pretty remote because it's on the
other side of the belt from where ceres
is
we saw it depicted in episode 105
on the show and the stories are a little
different book to show
so i'm just gonna generalize the idea of
what happened there
the massacre of anderson station was in
response to
a group of workers who took control of
the station the administrator from the
earth mars coalition
added a surcharge of three percent onto
supply transfers so you have this
captured workforce where else are they
gonna go
that are barely getting by in an
environment where people can't
naturally live you need air you need
water you need all these different
things that just don't exist there
so when discussing this three percent
increase it doesn't sound like a lot
the belter's dilemma is what do you do
do you go without air for three days out
of the year
do you go without food for three days
you get the idea
there's also an issue with their
children who are suffering from a
condition
known as cerebral hypoxia from
developing in a situation where there's
a low concentration
of oxygen in the air the group in charge
the anderson hyosung group refused to
provide them with aid
and in the show they won't even
recognize that there's something
happening to them
so the miners took over the station and
went on strike
this led to the corporation labeling
them as terrorists
and calling in the unn navy to help them
with the situation
in the show they say this happened 11
years before season 1 and we watched
mostly through the perspective of the
striking miners
in the novella we have two separate
timelines when it opens which is where
that excerpt i read at the beginning
came from
fred johnson has resigned from the
marine corps made a public statement
apologizing for what happened
and now he's generally hanging around
drinking at bars in the belt
some of anderson dawes's men come into
the bar and abduct him they have a
conversation
he basically calls fred out for being
suicidal
he says he's seen it a million times
he's seen guys that are about to
take themselves out and there's always
this part before
taking risks hoping the universe will do
it for you
make it easy fred doesn't necessarily
deny this
and you do get the sense that he is in a
period of self-loathing and he's having
a hard time
dealing with what happened anderson
dawes is actually really familiar with
what happened on the station because the
security camera footage recorded
everything and that got
out so the marine colonel fred johnson
brought an attack team to retake this
station
in alternating chapters fred recounts
this in his own mind as it happened
and anderson dawes asks him questions
about it while fred tries to figure out
why he abducted
him in the first place since as i
mentioned the details are different the
bottom line
of the attack is that fred did
everything he was supposed to do
he acted professionally he had to make
some tough choices
based on what he encountered and a lot
of people died
there were about 10 000 people who lived
and worked on anderson station
and over a thousand of them died in both
the book and the show
they were trying to surrender but
because their comms were being jammed
fred didn't get this message the assault
was caught by the surveillance cameras
and that was broadcasted across
the entire system back on earth fred was
awarded the medal of honor for his
actions but then also because that
footage got out
he became known as the butcher of
anderson station
what he learned later was that the un
had received their communication about
the surrender and basically they decided
to make an example out of them
anyway because they were counting on no
one ever finding out about the message
fred figured this out and this is from
his conversation with dawes
i killed him because he wanted her to
have enough air to breathe fred said
i killed her daddy while he was trying
to surrender and they gave me a medal
for doing it so there you go
that's what happened on anderson station
what are you going to do about it
dogs shook his head that's too easy you
killed lots of daddies what made this
one different fred started to speak
stopped tried again they used me they
made it about sending messages to
everyone that you don't [ __ ] with earth
because look at the [ __ ] we'll do just
because you spaced an administrator out
of nowhere station
they made me the poster boy for
disproportional response
they made me a butcher while they're
talking doss tells him a story about
killing his own sister when they were
teenagers
not on purpose and not through an act of
violence but by not thoroughly checking
the seals on her suit like he was
supposed to
it drives home how difficult it is to
live in space and how people who grow up
there
turn out different he talks about how
inners are wasteful
and we learned that the reason that he's
questioning fred is because he can't
have him going around
antagonizing people in the belt until
someone kills him he may be the butcher
to belters but he's the hero of anderson
station
in the inner planets and the opa can't
take the bad press if someone takes him
out
dawes says i don't waste resources
colonel
if you want to die it will do that girl
and her father absolutely no good if you
want to make it up to her
and all the people like her i could use
your expertise
you're a rare resource you've got
knowledge and training and as the man
who is famous throughout the whole
system for killing belters
you're in a position to be our strongest
advocate so based on the way he answered
things
dawes recruits fred into the opa and he
holds up his end of the deal
he does advocate for belters he tries to
improve conditions for them where he can
and eventually he'll represent the
largest faction of belters as an
earther and he's actually able to be
recognized by the united nations and the
martian republic
over the years we see him deal directly
with their leaders
and once he gets the proto-molecule
sample they sort of have to listen to
him and he does have a voice in
decisions that are made
so he's a super interesting character
and i really like this origin story and
i think that's a good place to end it in
the comments let me know what you think
about fred johnson
let me know if you have any questions
about him or the belt in general and
i'll try to answer what i can
the butcher of anderson station is
actually really short it's more like an
essay than a novella
even but i'll put a link in the
description of the video if you want to
check it out it definitely adds depth to
the character
and i don't think you'll be disappointed
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon